we win the game and we do have the
winner of the game akshat Chandra with
us in the studio actually
congratulations on your win thank you
appreciate it uh take us to the game so
I set the opening and I saw this move
Bishop F4 which is not very common so
it's yeah
I'm yeah I prepared something here I
just wanted to avoid like the main lines
that go after 906 92.9 C6 there's a lot
of theory there and I just wanted to get
something Fresh So what's the idea
behind this bishop before move I just
developed with Knight D2 and it's not
easy for black to decide which setup he
wants to play okay so he played D5 which
looks very natural so Knight D2 Queen B6
Castle
um so where do you think things started
to go well for you I think what he
played with Bishop Queen B6 and Bishop
Basics is already dubious I couldn't
remember why
but
with the king in the center it's
extremely risky to play on the queen
side like this probably he had to go uh
probably just Bishop E7 instead of Queen
B6 try to get his team to safety that's
probably the most accurate
wait like a night Castle a 92 first yeah
just you get like one of those normal
structures in the Sicilian uh I wouldn't
go see four here but I'd Castle oh yeah
okay and then you play with E5 an
interesting game
and do you think the bishop on F4 does
it benefit you having the bishop here
yeah I think he does it uh covers the G5
Square as well in some cases you go like
Knight f3h4 Bishop G5 Knight G5 so
Bishop
yeah something like this
oh H6 probably already probably black is
to play something like F5 here
yeah like Queen E2
looks better for white yeah it looks
Pleasant
so instead he
[Music]
after Bishop B4
I vaguely remembered Bishop E7 was like
the only move to not be much worse I
mean it's still worse for black but I I
think all other moves are just like much
much worse
so it's kind of frustrating when you
played Bishop before that I had no idea
what to do because it's probably close
to losing for uh for black I don't know
if what I played was correct there are
many options but it seemed decent enough
so did you spend
a lot more yeah I did because uh I
thought they should just like lose on
the spot somehow but he has this nice
idea with e takes D5 Knight takes d flat
it's like the only move to keep him in
the game because if C takes D5 Queen A4
check followed by C5 just wins a piece
are actually hard to face this queen A4
move to this position it's always a
threat and if he takes with the e-pawn
then he just opens up the E file and
that's bad yeah C5 yeah that's very nice
yeah taking with E4 upon this is yeah
right I also have C5 in between E2 which
is a nice trick but like even if I
didn't have that
there's always Rook if you want check
and black skin is in trouble
but after Knight D5 you must be happy
yeah but uh it was there was actually a
really nasty trick for black I think so
I spent a lot of time because I was
trying to make bishop E5 work but he has
oh wow and it's just a big mess like I
couldn't work out everything over the
board like yeah I take take
Queen E5 yeah Queen A4 Bishop takes D2
take on C6
King E7 Queen H6 and I was unable to
evaluate this position clearly I mean I
figured I should be better but his
darkspray Bishop's also pretty decent
and his Rooks are coming to the game so
yeah if you had rookie one right yeah so
nice yeah so Queen V7 is a huge threats
or something like Rook p8 yeah and oh
you don't have a check I don't anymore
it doesn't look very clear
so I figured Bishop G3 was good enough
then because if he goes 93 now I can
take and I have Knight F2
so Bishop g393 fe3 Queen E3 Knight F2
and we
oh sorry Bishop F2 here and then
whichever PC takes I have Queen A4 which
just wins yeah it feels like
yeah
okay yeah exactly so Bishop yeah but
this position with this king and the
urban Bishop is just so nice Rook d8 94.
I don't felt like the whole game he was
just barely hanging on
yeah I knew I should I knew I should be
better like it still wasn't easy to
figure things out over the board like
even here like the computer string plus
four I didn't think I was plus four
during the game I thought maybe I'm like
plus one and a half to plus two so what
did you consider here well 97 came as a
big surprise I didn't expect that at all
I thought he would go Queen D4
after 94.
because I thought if he moved the night
back it's just uh extremely passive yeah
I was gonna play Queen B3
but there are some tricky lines to work
out like I always have to calculate some
discovered night moves and
but yeah
something like night swear somewhere
I'm not sure to be honest I just figured
I'd play Queen B3 and I didn't see a
decent move for him so I didn't really
go further so like was if I Castle well
there I just go with D1 now okay sorry
and I support the bishop yeah
and everything's just hanging for him
yeah yeah this is
yeah this is very tricky
sorry
now it has to go so maybe some night
trick so now you have to take right
no I took him before here and I have 96
now these dark squares are extremely
weak
uh can I take this way hopefully I mean
I've met you five but probably oh my God
there's literally every piece is hanging
yeah this is bad so you want it here and
96 yeah this should be enough right yeah
I mean just running an exchange should
be winning
so instead
also probably I should just add here
that after yeah he can play 93 because I
just switch position uh the previous
move yeah 93 I take and got negative two
which is nice oh this is very much and
you can take on C4 but I just get too
many pieces for the queen
they should be winning
slowly alarm tangle like King H1 get my
knight into the game and oh he only has
a pawn yeah no he has two puns but okay
yeah but his pawns are like extremely
immobile so yeah you should be waiting
for white you have like nice outfits for
your pieces yeah this is very unusual to
have this kind of yeah between two Pants
versus her pieces okay so 97 was played
then A3 so he went for this yeah this is
all forced pigs
I have 96 anyway right yeah I think it's
just transport yeah exactly yeah not
here
if he takes on D6 it just transposed the
game
okay so he took it right here
yeah Bishop C5 is important
so did you think you're already winning
here or you just started I thought it
was much better I wasn't sure about
winning
uh Queen the age Queen F1 yeah a castle
Queen the one is a nice trick yeah Queen
demon is such a beautiful move
um I didn't expect him to Castle though
I thought he would play Knight C8 I mean
it looks terrible obviously with the
king in the center but then maybe you
could try to hold on here and try to
play for F6 later
yeah I was just gonna exactly play Rook
D1 and then bring my queen to like
the center or like the Queen's side the
queen C7 I guess they're like 22. yeah
pretty much anywhere I can move my queen
and then try to play for B5 or maybe
even Queen G4 ideas to like attack the
king side for some weaknesses yeah
that's not so he has to play like 97 and
B5 is very strong yeah it should be lost
but I thought maybe that was a better
try since in the game he's just losing
an exchange immediately he probably did
he miss quindy one uh probably because
otherwise I don't think he would go for
it yeah because if not Queen demand yeah
because the Rook dick says rookie eight
I mean I'm obviously better but it's not
winning by any stretch of the
imagination the night's coming to D5
yeah this is actually probably the best
position he said in a while yeah exactly
no Queen demand is just such like I
really like this kind of quietness
and we already showed that the point is
that takes takes there's no rogate
because of back rank
and after Queen D1
and I actually didn't see the rest of
the game so your conversion yeah
unfortunately foreign
[Music]
ideas if he takes on B4 yeah that's King
Instead This was played two three yeah
just stopping in United four ideas and
now my queen enters doesn't have moves
six
yeah now his position just collapses oh
so you just collected everything yeah I
just took the pawn and started pushing
the bee Pawn
and
for four and then Rook C6 okay and then
you're just gonna trade it exactly oh
wow yeah this was a really nice uh nice
game this queen D1
well this great start for you and
congratulations on your win and who you
play tomorrow I play I think Luca is
black
okay well good luck to you in the rest
of the tournament hope we see you back
here again thank you
okay and that was akshat's Chandra the
first decisive result of the day that we